let's start off by explaining how it
works yeah so is a client you sign up
you let us know your general size and
style preferences and then we'll have a
stylist will put together five things
for you to try at home so it's kind of
like having a boutique spend on your
favorite items like a fitting room
deliver to your home you simply try
everything on at home send back what you
don't want keep what you want easy-peasy
and I got my first stitch fix box over
the weekend so I had two out of five two
out of five things that I'm going to
keep is that is that pretty good and
diplomatic very good i think you know we
really think of that as being kind of
the model experience actually so the
idea is that you get five things you can
explore what's working for you what's
not working for you and choose seems
like kind of a good number where you're
going to be feel satisfied and feel I'm
excited about we are keeping and that
you got to choose what you love now one
thing that surprised me is that you guys
have 2,000 employees now and I wonder
how you scale this because you know
making sure that you're truly attending
to the personal desires of every single
customer is a really difficult job how
are you doing this absolutely and that
personalization is really what is unique
about such things so every single fix
the fix that you got is unique just for
you and not for anybody else and the way
we're able to achieve vet is actually
combining the best of both worlds and
art and science which is why we're here
the technology conference really and so
we have dozens of engineers we have over
40 data scientists who are all working
with us so that we can help build tools
so that our stylist can use algorithms
the best fix so there are buyers can use
algorithms to make sure we're stocking
the right styles so we really use the
best of Silicon Valley combined with
retail to be able to deliver this truly
personalized experience in a way that's
really scalable and one of the things I
was interesting that I enjoyed was these
little style cars that came with
different ways to style each items that
maybe I might not have thought of it you
know it wasn't just a shirt in a box
five buttons I know pinterest you ask
for information from Pinterest you ask
people to send you style boards how
optimistic are you about buy buttons a
lot of companies are experimenting with
them but we've yet to see real progress
yeah i mean i think the buy button is
really reflecting the way that people
are finding inspiration now and so i
think less and less people are finding
inspiration and the pages of magazines
are in the displays of stores but
they're finding inspiration on instagram
and pinterest and we certainly see that
at stitch fix's you think you are going
to buy life so i think that's where
people are finding their inspiration and
i think people will love to be able to
do an impulse buy with a button